what about zuckerberg with that
advertisement for autism medicine did
you see him
sliding across that lake on that thing
oh my god
with the american flag gun him down
back off my broccolini get your life
together
touch me bro i'm not touching you dude
stevie huh stevie watch your lunch i see
eh
brought a little snack for later huh
nick i want to steal your dog how much
give me a price he's priceless no he's
not though there's a price on every
house
suppose i were to offer you one million
dollars for one night with your wife
uh you want to bet on it hey dude let's
bet on the let's bet for the dog
what dog no that's sex trafficking or
not sex trafficking
trafficking no just i don't think you
should bet on an animal's life dude
actually [ __ ] it yeah yeah let's [ __ ] it
don't wager that bastard
he got furious uh wilder neither
fear fury all day well there's covet now
so it's not even gonna happen is it
ah furious camp got coded but i doubt
they'll figure it out
it's pirates figures it out it's irish
kobe that's right
that's supposed to be a fun time you
just drink guinness um
you got to put up something pretty happy
what are you putting up though i'm
putting up
the love of my life that you don't love
in that moment
5k he's cute he's eight though i have
another four
solid years with him you took that
orange gucci vest off him so you don't
care about him that much
yeah and you have turned it and you have
connor uh no
oh oh what you'll take wilder i'll take
fury
yeah let's do it five miranda okay
thanks for the race can i get your dog
uh yeah and clear it with my girl see if
she'll let me take this off
because y'all were just talking about
getting a dog remember oh i kind of want
a puppy though because i think he's
damaged goods
he's a little skittish ptsd i believe
his first family
beat him oh god every dog it's like dude
is he a rescue yeah but where are all
these dogs from they're from where
memphis or something like
what do you how is every dog like he
came over on the mayflower his
grandfather
i found him on the first 48. yeah he
only has three legs and you look at he
has four legs you're like no he doesn't
he snuck over the border i feel like
you're just i feel like you're just
doing this to hype up the price of this
house yeah
he's a sweet dog no no he's stevie man
good to see you man yeah you too man
it's been a while
it has been so you're wearing the last
time for the bait and switch
i heard what happened and yeah your mom
got involved and i'm sorry
stevie was mad he thought i set him up
no no there was no set up i just you
know i i'm taking a break i'm just uh
just
chilling right now and uh yeah just
you got that fresh face i just kind of
simmered down on that i i
you know with the initial breakup i'm
like yeah i want a date but now i think
i'm like
i'm gonna take it slow you know i am
talking to your little pussyhound when
you got singing hey brother don't use
that kind of language if you don't mind
man
um i'm just yeah i'm sorry ron white for
halloween why are you dressed like this
huh
are you wrong are you turning to ron
white dude ron
white can't even remember his name he's
like what does ron mean
we're like that's you ron
dude i interviewed ron white one time
and he's a beautiful man he's
16. he's 60 or 70 100 years old
and i interviewed him one time beautiful
hair you know
if he he's the kind of guy if he died
i'd go up to the coffin and cut a little
bit of his hair and take it
yeah interviewed him for two and a half
hours okay
saw him the next day at the comedy store
oh that guy's a old-time comic isn't he
yeah he's all-time great dog he's on the
blue comedy yeah that guy's uh
originally like hitler texas or
something right yeah
apparently he did this interview at
restoration hardware how do you guys sit
on the couch like that we did it at his
house man
that's this house yeah is he a nice guy
he's a really nice really nice guy
yeah he yeah he's a super nice guy he's
a businessman though what people don't
realize is that that vip stuff that
comics i used to it but that when you do
the meet and greet
he owns that whole business that's all
him yeah oh
he looks like he drinks too does he
drink alcohol whiskey oh i knew it yeah
he'll be on stage with whiskey and a
cigar oh
no he's a legend but he also did
um ayahuasca this is what i've heard he
did ayahuasca six months ago and he
hasn't had a drink since then
oh wow oh it cures you he did it at a
marriott
hey am i allowed to do that even though
i'm in a program can i do that once huh
ayahuasca i'm not your sponsor hey nice
try to get it out of me but
yeah yeah yeah nice dragons yeah i know
i'm just asking for
cocaine if it's a friday right just
asking hey guy that's
smoking crack over here do you think it
would be
okay well that's a yes just once
look i could do it it's not addictive i
don't know that program either there's a
lot of wellness things happening right
now and brennan you need to know more
about this kind of stuff right
especially with your brain damage or
whatever i heard that microdosing is the
new
hotness on the street that's not that's
old that's four months ago the new thing
that people's doing now
uh mdma stuff nad
and the nad what is that that nad drive
have you ever done it too i haven't done
it
it's basically medieval torture is it
really a nightmare
don't let rogan talk you into nad drip
he did to me i was doing it for four
weeks
it's medieval torture but what is it
what happens what do they do they put in
your system right
yeah they put an iv and that drips and
takes about an a if you're taking a long
time dude if you're
moving fast you can do it about an hour
usually takes about two hours i could
get it
pure [ __ ] what is it i think rogue is
the fastest we just open up the
floodgates he didn't like i don't know
18 minutes or something but you feel
like awful
i'll do the suppositories pure silver
what is it
it's pure silver stevie what is that
though what does it do to your body
listen i didn't feel anything off of it
i think it takes some time you probably
dude it sounds like you got involved in
something
different you know i was using rogan's
nad guy man
yeah i can't believe you guys know him
i'm a big fan of that guy
you know are you though yeah really
joe really what are you a fan of because
you're not that into
no cause i've like i've seen you on so
many joey diaz you you
i watch all of it oh yeah yeah i look up
to him
yeah look i think a lot of people look
up too yeah is he a nice guy in real
life though
yes he's real like down to earth great
guy okay yeah yeah yes he's just real
like curious
he's like the most curious guy i ever
met probably he's like curious about
everything you know he like wants to
know things
yeah where i'm like and you yeah we
don't give a [ __ ]
well i care about you you do you can't
know stuff
i i feel like and i choose not to okay
that's a difference
you guys done the sleep deprivation
tanks that does he really have that
dude i live near an interstate okay i've
done [ __ ] sleep deprivation
yeah i've done those tanks but you get
naked
yeah i don't suggest that either okay
okay i'll suggest that either
yeah i actually peed in my ice bath the
other day so yeah i jacked off on those
things
oh did you oh yeah you said that huh not
for me the old freaking yolk in the egg
bro this one's got double yolks in it
yeah so what's been going on with you
man i noticed it's been taking it mellow
you seem really calm today i am i feel
like you're in a good place
yeah i just i i just i've been you know
kind of thinking about things and i'm
like i should just because i'm gonna be
a lot busier with uh scissor bros and
we're gonna we'll we're gonna release do
a patreon now so i got to get ready
to do it twice a week yeah and then with
my own podcast
so three times a week yeah so that and
just a lot of things i need to be more
responsible you're gonna kill yourself
son
you're doing good you're trying to get
you know get to the big boy a little bit
i feel you
i'm mad at your brother right now i
texted him i text i group text him and
santino
santino takes me right back your brother
still hasn't respond
you were there at his fourth of july
party you guys didn't show up
i didn't get invited yeah i didn't get
the invite either oh you think it's
funny
yeah i thought you for sure you think
it's funny not to be invited first of
all
america's party yeah for sure yeah
so let's be honest andrew was there yeah
i'm sure the best friends
i didn't know he was married yeah great
she's nice nice yeah who knows if he's
married or not you can't tell
so i would have loved to see you guys
there how was the party
really fun it was really kind of you
know just
low-key i never got invited either why
did chris julia's party
i did me too i did i never got invited
by
uh santino i invited you to my party
yeah you did you're the only friend i
invited you know what i would like is uh
he goes to a korean spa
and you know paulie's been there it's
just a spot is it we spa
no no no no you know we spot god in
trouble have you heard about whispers
i'm telling the story tell them what i
should go to
spot all the time when i was fighting
because it's like a
korean bath they have like real cold ice
bathing and switch between them
well apparently they let this
transgender
uh identifies as a woman but it's a man
with you know big dick
so this woman's in there with her kid
her daughter slang in his rod
and she's like she comes out she's like
dude this guy has a dick like yeah
but he he considers himself a woman
she's like i don't care
yeah like my kid shouldn't be eye-to-eye
with this guy's big-ass dick that's a
man with a dick yeah
and the wii spot was like well he she
identifies as a as a woman she's like
dude bro
i don't care there's a dick in the
women's bathroom oh yeah
we're in a different time now like most
places we're not dude
no you when you're identical right and
most places would be like well you need
to go identify somewhere else okay
because
99.9 of people are one or the other
yeah so we can't adjust the whole rules
what they should have is a separate
section for people that are trans
that's a good idea they need to have a
trans uh have a trans olympic
section have a trans world championship
boobs and a penis in four years yeah
yeah okay you know how hard it would be
to run with boobs and a penis i feel
like i'd love to watch them do it
i mean i'd watch it you know yeah the
most olympic [ __ ]
yeah it'd be better especially when they
hit those hurdles dude they're not
hitting the hurdles oh trying to keep
that [ __ ] [ __ ] up off that hurdle
i'm into it or the long jump big ass
dick flapping yeah yeah i'm into it we
gotta mix things up man so anyway would
you guys be open to going to the korean
spa with me and bob
dude we can't even get anybody to do
bobby's japanese party or whatever it
was
okay well first of all it's our party
that we started he came over here
and then [ __ ] didn't invite us to it
yeah it kind of hurts our feelings
tell him we're hurt should i yeah he's
not gonna text you back he won't even
give you work we're the only one giving
you any words
i mean what are you even talking about
here your brother's straight up
hollywood now bro
oh lord you're right dude you could have
a baby by now
i know okay i'd be living in a shack huh
yeah yeah i mean steve cook me with some
rice dude yeah
look at us give me five dollars hey bob
hmm all right you know i just got a pair
of these man
and i'm uh uh uh uh i'm enjoying them
you know they used to call me flamingo
feet when i was growing up
because you could see my tarsals through
my skin real easily
i kind of had the like the foot of like
a
you know archaeologists man when they go
into rocks and then they find that bird
phalanges
and you'll see it's uh boneage in there
that's what i got they used to call me
flamingo feet
well all birds tree runners
cover any type of feet start to take
some steps towards
normalcy in this wild new world that's
right all
birds tree runners i got a pair and
they're
you know what's great about them they're
comfortable but they look
nice that's a hard thing to find
it also seemed like heck you could
almost stop and play a game in a game of
hoops if you wanted to
yeah they're made from sustainable
natural materials that feel light on
your feet
and are better for the planet you know
you don't want to
you know 200 years from now a child digs
up a damn dirty
reebok or something in his yard that
won't happen
all birds tree runners are breathable
machine washable that's
good and made with responsibly
sourced eucalyptus tree fiber damn
you'll have a damn koala at you nipping
at your damn
feet hoofs reasonably sourced eucalyptus
tree fibers
comfy breathable packaging made from 90
recycled cardboard
oh they're helping out the tree runner
is carbon neutral thanks to sustainable
practices
certified as a public benefit
corporation
and man they're nice you can wear them
if you just
you got to go to the airport i'm taking
a flight they're easy it's easy to get
them on and off i love them
all birds tree runners that's it you're
going to love them
i do you know i've needed mental help
most of my life and probably even after
i'm dead
i'll have to hire somebody to come to
the grave site and
and damn tinker with my brain bones
well in the meantime there's better help
you know better help is a place
that you can get serviced for any type
of mental issues or suffering you have
going on
there's a broad range of expertise
available through better help
which may not be locally available
sometimes locally you can't get nobody
they send you to miss pam or miss
bridgette and she don't know nothing
she's dealing with stuff and she got a
burn on her arm from who
from from god knows what well this is
different
this service is available for clients
worldwide better help
is committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches for you
it's more affordable than traditional
online counseling and financial aid
is available that's beautiful better
help want you to start living a happier
life today
i have used better health visit
betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s that's b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p
and join the over one million people
who've taken in charge of their mental
health
with the help of an experienced
professional
this podcast is sponsored by better help
and king and the sting listeners get 10
off their first month at betterhelp.com
k-a-t-s
if you need help look into it what do
you got
nick yeah what do you got nick we do
have updates from our dating game winner
and uh savannah who's still dating i
wasn't dating him but nobody's got a
date you were gone that
time look i will say this though i
watched the episode that you did mm-hmm
who's a hooker she was a looker
yeah sorry i get my l's and h's mixed up
you know what i'm saying okay okay okay
lurby lancock dude one of my favorite
signers of the
independence document
no algorithm struggles you
remember this guy you watched the
episode
this is a male nurse first of all he's a
massage therapist or
a physical therapist a physician's
assistant i think
something male nurse i think is pretty
much all encompassing so they
they traded numbers right they got each
other's beautiful young men
young fella take it easy guys i am
taking my music all right i can't be
wearing that shirt throwing that out
there what do you got
uh yeah and they've been talking they've
been chatting and they gave us an update
on how it's going
oh so a date happened uh really one's in
minnesota one's in idaho oh that's right
but but we savannah gave us permission
to give
andrew her number and they've been
they've been talking so let's see i'm
surprised stevie didn't try to fly over
there and slip her that winker baby
being a good boy man
are you i'm trying to do the right thing
trying to relax on the house
and i can feel it you see him in a
better head space yeah that's
relaxed yeah probably probably going
back to that fake butt
you don't have to i know how he's
faithful
look how good he's doing it's
reparations get in there dude it's in
the closet
get in there and deposit egg now you
what have you heard of a tanga egg
tang egg yeah look it up real quick so
we put the egg
that you put um this liquid this sticky
vaseline gooey liquid and you place it
on the head of your dick
and you you cut you uh stroke it you
stroke it and it's like
have you seen an alien like alien one
when the alien yeah pops out
yeah out of the chest yeah yeah you see
like the head of your penis doing that
now why don't you check it out man now
it sounds like you just use cad berry
eggs
it's basically yeah that's what it is
yeah tanga egg i think
it's japanese yeah there's like you're
jacking off with a ghost it feels
fantastic
wow yeah how did you find out about that
and this is someone sent me and jeremiah
one in the post office
oh that sounds like a great so he used
it one night he did it standing up
oh he's getting married with the kids
let's do the hand motion please
how quick to the lawsuit where scissor
bros
has penises out around scissors okay
that's a
end job right there what do you mean
we'll talk to hr stevie
as soon as some guy sees one of your
videos gets his
urinator out and he also has scissor
bros he has a couple pieces of scissors
on the counter because he's a huge fan
he's snipping around like nips his
freaking goose stick
it's a rap player don't put that on the
universe it's just
me you you're the one out there
monkeying around
i know i know but please don't do that
if you're listening
don't don't cut your dudes scissor bows
very dangerous title because
of the you know what i'm saying what if
we're the knife boys you know how soon
we're you know
no we're playing we're machete boys you
think that's smart
yeah we're doing something positive what
about grenade cousins
you think that's what we're doing is
positive yeah real positive
about good energy somebody yeah positive
till it's not steve
no one's going to cut their penises off
be surprised man people are wild
be surprised dude really yeah
at home ladies and gentlemen don't cut
anything down there
please it's so but if do you cut your
pubic hair
no you don't want people cutting you
guys don't have any coverage there's no
way you have any liability insurance you
it's a wrap do we need that
huh yeah oh you're putting fear
installing fear in my heart
it's not fair that's fine it's too long
dawg i've been doing this too long
that's fine so you know the gate like
mm-hmm so how do we do we have to do a
name we'll talk off airmen okay no
problem i'm talking i like i like
bad friends but whatever yeah but you
know what well what about kindergarten
scissor bros the rounded scissors
what's what difference does that make
fifth grade bros
a whole a fifth grade rose's game oh
cause those scissors are rounded they're
not as sharp
yeah they're those little round ones
yeah all it takes is some little
freaking
you know some little [ __ ] snot muppet
out there
you know to clip his own [ __ ] gander
wand open and they'll play
the hood he decides to snip it himself
yeah or something he nips out an ovary
trying to diy
freaking um it's a lawsuit isn't it
could be where'd you learn this scissor
bros two guys
two freaking closeted gay men i like
good friends too
huh i like good friends yeah your
brother took that from me before we gave
you a job i think santino took that from
oh that's true santino dude
santino's really bobby's brother yeah
okay
dude now you're really getting to the
core this is like a therapy session i'm
sorry i should have said that man i love
you oh that's funny
it just makes me it makes me sad they're
making good money
they are they're making good they are
they're steve jobs you're working the
first oh i'm in the kitchen washing
dishes man yeah
good for them all right i love them do
you do you do you
i do and i don't let's listen to this
what's up guys this is andrew just
giving an update on me and savannah
um so we've been talking a little bit
and uh initially we really hit it off
and we seem to have a lot in common
and she's a really cool girl but the
minnesota thing is making it tough you
know being 19 hours away from each other
it's hard to meet up but if you guys are
willing to set something up for us i
would still love to meet her you know
have her here for a weekend and throw
her a good time and
you know we could film it it could be
like chin and hot carl
except you know we might get wasted but
we will actually do
some stuff after and you know i wouldn't
be drinking he's staring at her
the whole time just kidding i love you
guys i love you brendan i love you theo
and i just love the
show gang gang buzz buzz baby thank you
man
well 19 hours yeah you're driving bubba
that's a short
flight yeah that's a great point if
you're in a spirit airline we'll get you
there pretty fast
yeah if you are in a conestoga wagon
you're probably looking at about 30
hours he's like that's a seven
week track man yeah if you're walking
bubba we're gonna send you on southwest
he's like hopefully next spring what do
you tell a guy like this steven when
you've got a great haircut
um he's got a nice he's handsome
you can tell he has good hygiene he's
responsible oh
there we go yep here we go look at those
freaking
front muppets huh those guys
don't know it's savannah here with a
little dating game update
thank you guys again for having me on it
was so much fun
me and andrew decided to call it quits
because i realized how far away
minnesota really is from idaho
um theo it's not too late for you to
shoot your shot go ahead and slide in my
dms
i'll come to nashville that's not too
far away
uh but i do have a lot of weird dms
in my instagram inbox a few blue check
marks that i'm not mad about
um a lot of men offering to fly me to
toronto
texas so i can be their southern girl
one guy saying that he's not from idaho
but he'd love to be my potato
and a lot of guys who found my linkedin
but thanks again
it's been a weird experience it's been
fun gang gang buzz buzz
oh i know what she says either i'm this
guy says either i'm coming to idaho
you're coming to toronto
eli you don't belong with any of these
guys sent in videos not january she's
trying to get daddy's sugar b
she likes you i just figured it out this
whole thing
she likes well we knew that from the
jump yeah she made it pretty clear
she wants that dark art shaft she likes
she wants some of that uh
god damn that's her no that's britney
spears
theo's comments on savannah just made me
recall this uh
looking funny
nice friend yeah dude i'm a fan
you guys are being mean what no worries
that's a beautiful lady that's a
beautiful lady you're the one
underground and railroad some dark butt
dude yeah he's still
shooting shots at pretty [ __ ] i swear
and here's what's interesting
i could see it happening bro thanks
player damn look at that hard part
somebody tried to set us up one time
years ago
yeah i used to know her cousin when i
was in college come on man
wait is she from new orleans come on man
that's like double d's is she's from
louisiana right deal
you're a strange guy man i love you
we're just saying come on man
is she from louisiana yeah she's from
kentwood louisiana
bro this is a match made in she has a
husband bro no she does if she's married
she's no she's married she's not married
anymore dude and if she is i'll do a
[ __ ] saving silverman
and break him up for you i will do that
for you no you can't that guy's jacked
her husband what about that
is she married nick uh i don't think so
but
i'll take that other this is yeah this
is the other girl idaho britney spears
well here's the wild thing
did did the one man know that they
weren't going to have a chi
because i he seemed kind of he's into it
and she was like not a chance
she's like we're dunzos but where's that
firefighter dude stevie
yeah that guy was that was a dude i mean
you're welcome the marlboro man
he's fighting fires that's what happened
to him i think he had probably asthma or
something
yeah which i don't even believe in
savannah johnson we'll see maybe if i
get to boys i'll take you out for a soda
or something
soda yeah something cream soda
cream soda cream soda no but she really
likes you
you know that no idea this is a video i
know but i know i know no she could be
surprised
she's in the tub she really likes you no
they don't
no she does she does and you've been
dressed
you've been dressing you could tell man
i know what you're doing i know what you
have about seven shirts
she wants your babies dude i know i'm
not doing any babies out there i know
but i'm just saying she really
imagine a baby trying to crawl down a
mountain
they live in ottawa they're living oh
that's right yeah
have you performed in boise i would do
salt flat baby
have you done boise yet uh yeah i've
done boys how long ago though
it'd been it was the dark arts tour it's
also pretty recent
yeah not too yeah about two years ago
okay you know what's up he's gonna
because
boise is fantastic yeah man boys is
great dude i think it would be great to
meet her sometime and see if we love
each other
i hope it happens oh yeah it could
happen dude dude i want you and britney
spears to
be together dude i do i said i shot my
shot corner we'll put her in the car
dude you shot your shot with her whitney
spears yeah he said yeah
he said them yams she's gonna see that
he's the top comment dude
hashtag free brittany who wants some
front yams dude it's amazing you know
what i'm saying them freaking rip
them right that's rib nuggets baby them
[ __ ]
them sternum hams though hit me one more
time
i'm in uh who's is this george the guy
you used to fight
uh no it could cause ducking dude
no i'm not ducking i like the kid i'm
not talking you're ducking everybody
dude you sure you are i like him
ducking everybody 35 i'm 130 pounds
because you have speed
and 35 pounds i weighed myself at the
korean spa dude 135.
it's called the spa to you first of all
and
i don't say i'm going to the american
louisiana this weekend
i'm sorry i don't know what else to call
it theo
just look at your history man no man
what
that's the right way korean spa dude no
it's just in k-pop
it was right bro no but korean spot it's
a different thing
it's not let's go to our registration
korean
back chin back me up i say when we talk
to each other
it's a spa but when we're talking to you
guys it's a korean spot i rest my
channel your career we know it's korea
when you tell them
hey jim when you when when you go to
korean barbecue let's say you invite
stevie do you go hey we're going to
korean barbecue
just say we're going to bar you know
what i do both
well that's just wrong i do both because
i don't go hey anyone want american
barbecue
damn remember when bobby cared about
stevie when they were kids yeah
a long time ago sorry years ago it just
breaks my heart i was writing about it
in my diary the other day what did you
say
i drew a picture of you drew a picture
of bobby
and then no and then i just i just
you tore it in half said on fire no i
just thought about it
and i just said man you guys were close
then yeah yes what happens now or
you know movies and stuff yeah he just
went to uh
hungary yeah big movie yeah yeah but
look at luke wilson gets his brother in
the movie
you know even with that nose still in
the movies
right dude who else gets their brother
murphy got his brother in there yeah
charlie murphy it killed him oh yeah
chris rock too how's it going rock yeah
oh the wayans oh they get there yeah
you know what i mean oh brothers dude
the waynes will jerk off in a napkin and
then get the napkin in the movie
everybody in the movie anybody but
wayne's dna is getting in the movie
you got to get in there i know so what
do i say hey
you're out here [ __ ] me up with your
agent bob yeah is that why i do
text him hey [ __ ] me with caa dude like
i got my head shots ready man
he's your ca agent yeah he's the agent
like hey i'll do the move by the way
my brother giving him too much he's got
that much
power like i think he does i think he's
getting there what
um i don't know about that but i'm
talking about like i think us saying he
does
yeah yeah you guys are on the same level
what are you talking about
well i wouldn't say bobby and i are on
the same level you're on look at this
studio
oh yeah it's great he doesn't have this
stuff i know he doesn't that's why i'm
saying i wouldn't say bobby and i are on
the same level
bobby's hollywood though well well thea
is getting pretty hollywood too
i stay out of it man i'm hoping you're
getting up there too
the closest thing i even know to
hollywood is you me you no you know a
lot of people man
they know who you are you hang around
with oh more famous people than i do
i don't know about you you probably you
know you had dinner last night with
david spade
yeah that's true you [ __ ] jerk off
the [ __ ] uh christmas thing no uh
i bailed out a chris pratt's movie
you're right yeah yeah
you're right you're you're with uh kid
rock every other weekend on the camera
that's right i'm connected man yep keep
going
keep going where just by your connection
but i'm not going right there's no way
but he's up there right
thank you he's up there there's nowhere
else to move though
like you moved this is our hollywood no
but
you have the freedom if you wanted you
could probably get a house out here too
if you wanted
he could yeah i know how much he makes i
don't want no house out here
all right fair enough but that's your
decision but if i did have it you could
come and stay with me i wouldn't make
you stay
in hud housing rental apartments
somewhere i like my apartment
it's a beautiful apartment i appreciate
the offer my brother
would be staying with me if you want my
brother stays with me guest house guest
house at least easily
yes shallette yeah at least right take
the water
like in the garage they call it a casita
if you're mexican
in the casitas yes yeah dude you should
be in the casita dude how do i get
through the bob though because he's
catering to collat you know he's gotta
be here
he's taken care of there that's great
george i know it's around
a lot of people that have you know i
don't want to say yeah typ taking your
place
but you know i hate to use acronyms that
hurt people's feelings
but look man you're welcome here and
then i said this i love the episode when
you guys did with eric griffin man
you did i i just tuned in to make sure
that you guys even got the thing off
you usually hate the episodes right when
you're not here it was the dating game
it's not my favorite when i'm not here
because i wish that i was here but yeah
i
you did loved it what'd you like about
it i felt like there was some kind of
beef between between i felt a little
beef between you and eric but i felt
like
you feel any animosity towards stevie
towards me
no i only that was a fake beef because i
i was that one
that was my entry point to the fart
spray challenge the arm wrestle
yeah because y'all were so organized
with your chronological
yeah so i had no time to get a word in
because you know what about eric's so
fast on his toes he's a talker yeah he
gets oh
every second that's not this remote no
he's got punches boom
he talks though he's mentally quick
mentally
i'm not that quick i'm like slow i'm
like oh you're a different speed yeah
i'm just very slow
yeah yeah you're like
[Music]
yeah i just slowly getting into it yeah
yeah that needs to change too they need
to start saying hey aren't you steve
steve's brother yeah
give me six months you're the one who's
actually still getting some leg out
there in the world you're flying out to
what
washington wasn't getting hickeys
mugging down some target worker dude
okay that's that's way better bobby's
over here
bobby's over here still making love to
the same
woman watch your words theo i love her
okay okay okay everyone in here
okay okay okay and i've already written
down certain walls and stuff around town
that i love her fair enough and
um just saying wherever wherever we'll
accept it
uh they're a good match man they're a
great man yeah yeah power couple
they're a great man so amazing beautiful
both of them beautiful win
they need to have kids i don't know if
bobby can have them
he has jewelry yeah i mean no i'm baking
silk shoes dude
i weighed them at the spa how much gas
200
180 180 and most of it was gristle
five four 180. his body fat was 69
he was 88 body fat dude like an elephant
seal
his body fat it said cool whip came up
yeah
you think a baby elephant seal yeah oh
if he doesn't die by clubbing i won't
even know
how it all works i will not even know
how the world even works
what about you back there if i can seem
a nipple what are you doing you alive
you forgot your vape pen today so nobody
wants to talk to him
forgot his [ __ ] paper know your role
dude
it's a great mr d shirt though so he
fully redeemed yours now your role does
paul revere show up with a hoarse voice
no he doesn't dude
bring your [ __ ] vape stick daddy all
right and we want the coconut one not
that other one you had one time
you're not that [ __ ] grape or
whatever laser lime no no no it was uh
red energy yeah okay what are you trying
to do
yeah who you putin get the [ __ ] out of
here
sorry i'm on one today let's go blue
chew you know it
i've been on it hell i probably have
half of one in my system right now
because i got a date that didn't go well
and i mean it went fine but i just
i just i don't know i took it and i
didn't need to or whatever who knows god
i need some help but blue chew is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as viagra or
cialis
but in chewable form don't you want to
chew your wiener
to wellness you should it's an online
prescription service no visits to the
doctor
no awkward conversations with some man
in an alley or a woman or lesbian or gay
man
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
it ships right to your door discreet
packaging
your neighbors will never know oh would
they get a new seesaw would they get
would they get a tonsillectomy who knows
blue chew
the tablets are made in the usa baby you
could taste the gasoline
and um they prepare and ship direct it's
cheaper than a pharmacy
that's true we got a special deal for
our listeners try blue chew
free when you use our promo code kats at
checkout
just pay five dollar shipping that's
bluechw.com
promo code kats to receive your first
month free and we thank bluechu
for sponsoring this podcast and we thank
you for being a part of our lives i love
you
gang baby american home shield
that's what i'm wanting to tell you
about man if you you know a shield helps
stop something stop a arrow
stop a fireball or something out of a
dragon
stop stuff you need that stuff stopper
that's why i'm telling you american home
shield
you know this summer's hot it's spicy
so don't let a broken ac fridge or other
home
repair get in the way of your summer fun
man you trying to finagle with some
little fella or something some little
of age woman or man and now you can't
because the dang ac's out
and y'all sweating out of y'all's body
that's right american home
shield choose from different plans
they offer a choice of three great plans
to help cover the cost of repair
replace parts of major home systems and
appliances
no matter their age so if something goes
bad you got a refrigerator that goes bad
you got a dang washer dryer and ac
you're covered you don't need that
hassle it's expensive
that's right if american home shield
can't repair the covered item they'll
replace it
service fees limitations and exclusions
apply see plan
for details coverage available
no matter how old your systems or
appliances are
and we have an exclusive 50 off for
listeners of this show that's right
to celebrate 50 years of providing
homeowners peace of mind you can take
50 smackers off their most comprehensive
plan ever go to ahs.com
k-a-t-s to save 50 that's
ahs.com k-a-t-s for fifty dollars
off any planned service fee limitations
and exclusions applies you plan for
details
american home shield be sure with the
shield
oh i love when you're i see what you're
doing over here
yeah take it easy yeah that's gonna be
my dog soon
take it easy
i'm just saying whatever spell you put
on this there's no spelling okay
this is just pure love all right why'd
you just order a bunsen burner on amazon
what are you implying i'm gonna eat the
terrier how dare you
i would never i would never eat a
yorkshire terrier
you son of a girl you know let's say the
son of a gun
dare you i was not dude
you said bunch of burner my man no
you're implying that i was gonna cook
this
because you just little young biggest
tempura fryer in the market
was awake smelling it the dog was awake
when you
got here the dog was on my lap the dog
liked me okay
the dog did like yeah okay yeah i'm just
saying
now the dog appears to not be doing he's
unconscious
god loves me dude he trusts me he does
he trusts anything right now okay
he went right into my lap right here you
saw brendan
this dog loves me whose dms are these
we talked about that one uh yeah let's
keep going let's get into the episode
man
stevie had a bunch of suitors and i'm
sorry stevie i love you dude i got upset
i got upset oh you you got upset i think
there's a thing with bobby just like
why you know when i was growing up my
dad he had some older kids
yeah and they were really wealthy
yeah and they didn't treat him well i
was a kid we didn't have any money or
anything and they made him live in like
uh
and i know you live in a nice place i'm
not saying that but they just didn't
like yeah they made him live in a shack
there were people stabbings and
shootings all the time outside brothers
out there
right somebody stabbed him some black
guy stabbed him with a screwdriver
but um yeah i just don't want to see it
in like that because
theo take care of ours yeah that's right
i bought my brother carr
we pay you every time you come in here
don't we yeah you're starting to now
yeah turn to now i appreciate that guys
yeah and i'm not judging bobby i know
he's busy
you know i know he's got a lot of mouths
to feed but sometimes you gotta stop and
smell your brother
yeah but the first steak i get goes to
my brother's lips
you take care of uh and that's from game
of thrones yeah older brother he'll be
here next week
you got him a car gt3 it's a toyota
celica
it's nice it's 91. so we had a bunch of
suitors for stevie
one girl i was like is really into him
and someone was like she really though
if she was so tired
don't be scared you gotta help him out
with this with his confidence confidence
man
this was his reaction and someone was
like well she liked him so much why
didn't she slide in his dms
well she sent proof that she actually
did slide in
no that's not my instagram man oh it is
it is
hold up man call me it says too
i like is that the girl from montana or
whatever yep dude this girl
is so thirsty for you
i don't know i think that i've never
received that one no that's him
sending a message what was that no
that's her no that's her sending to him
never never got it
i think that's fabricated guys what is
your handle is that her handle yeah
that's right
who is my korean name that's my handle
thank you
nice to meet you sir it's nice to
finally meet you
who you are i'm being honest i that's
the first time i'm seeing that
yeah yeah i'm sure y'all love dm i would
respond back to that one stevie she's a
beautiful woman
yeah but you know i'm trying to you know
and maybe enter a different another
program where
it works on that are you a sex actor
yeah i think i think yeah i mean dude i
have a black butt i got flashlights
you got that weird egg thing your jacket
you've got the tanga egg there's things
going on
yeah it's just trying to slow it down
you know what i mean but dude how are
you i tell you cruz book you got a
little bit
maybe an animated person would yeah i'll
wait for a robot
to get your frustration in other ways
why don't you fight the kid i thought
you guys were setting up the matter at
thick boy studio i'm trying to say we
are we have full match ready for you to
go with the big boy i want to do it two
weeks tuesday
or no next week next tuesday are you
down to wrestlemania have you seen the
space
huh yes it's huge we have we have
wrestling mats
oh man i'm a bug 35 yeah i'm like out of
shape your arm wrestled
you're not out of shape i saw your back
early when you changed shirts good shape
you feel good
and your legs your legs are popping oh
good shape you can stick and move on
this big boy no i need you to get that
giraffe
hike up a run in and get my my heart
rate that's not going to help
what no it is what if what if you and i
worked on some moves that are
guaranteed to work you can train me man
why don't you just cry by the mail slot
for 10 minutes that'll get your heart
going
you could teach me jiu-jitsu let me let
brendan
train me and we'll get some of that
footage i i want to do this up well if
anak do some voice over on the lead up
bruce buffer announce you guys
well what is it a wrestling match or
what what just wrestling just wrestling
just wrestling straight wrestling just
like you in high school
remember that one time yeah that's just
him trying to lose weight oh you guys
are going to wrestle
there's no you guys really want to see
this huh i well i think here's what
i think you're going to beat him dude
i'm 135 pounds he's less than 300 dude
you're vince papalia fighting just
[ __ ] sign up for it
and here's the thing we need singlets we
need cat singlets
okay we already looking into it thank
you
and so we're going to need a few more
weeks
if we do it next week people are not
going to be ready i want theo here
yeah yeah i thought we're doing a tag
team thing with me and jeremiah we could
wear a wwf
remember you said i could tag him in
what about you said i could talk about
jeremiah because the cardio
against the big boy that's fair tag team
we tie one of jeremiah's arms you guys
back so fast that's fair enough
no way no if stevie's just gassing out
how about that you could just use one
arm no no no you can use your all your
appendages
but the big boy he come on then it's
even because they both weigh in they'll
be about first of all
the big boy has a name what's his name
george
and paris jackson george jackson
i would like to say that in honor of
whites and asians in here
the master mix michael jackson michael
jackson yeah michael jackson's kid
iced jiu jitsu with him it's a girl
she has a brother though who's this
huh bro start dating michael jackson's
daughter
then sky's the limit dog get her
pregnant you see that
i just went to a month retreat for a
week retreat for sexual wellness dude
that's what i'm talking about you really
did yeah see i need to do
i need to give you you would he went to
oh so you went to arizona yeah you went
to that scottsdale yeah how did it work
that's a good one it's good how did that
work you came here you have
nine dates dates but i'm not
masturbating in a dark anus i'm not
doing uh
there's no levels to this game yeah
there's levels and i was on really
tell yeah all right brendan at least i
had admitted it yeah i do
first step yeah yeah what about
zuckerberg with that
advertisement for autism medicine did
you see him sliding across that lake on
that thing oh my god
with the american flag gun him down
could there be a bigger dork oh my god
what is going on this isn't an ad for
autism medication
i don't know what is dude what is his
problem paul reverse
dude turn around this is the next promo
for
love on the spectrum around dude
it looks like he won season season seven
of alone
dude i'd fist fight this little [ __ ]
broad hard scarf this [ __ ]
god i'd love to set up that zuckerberg
bridge theo oh
oh that'd be amazing people said
immediately after this video he sold all
our data to russia
for sure this is the end of it right
yeah that's him heading over to russia
that's a great commercial all right
what's this big boy want this gentleman
wants some help he he's 19 doesn't have
his license
okay driving license yo bernatha what up
man it's dale yankovich from
ponchatoula louisiana man shout out cubs
and i had never been to that [ __ ]
boy
if theo says it's nice it's nice i was
wondering if y'all give me some advice
man uh
i just started driving recently you know
i'm 19. my mom's been on my ass for a
while about driving and [ __ ]
i still have my driver's license though
and my driver's test is coming up
and i get [ __ ] i'm not gonna get
nervous you know
when when i'm when i gotta take the test
but i found out that little
you hit a little bit of that taco you
feel a little better on my driving test
but i know i couldn't take it on my
driving test i probably feel that [ __ ]
i was worried about any good remedies
for me like what could help me pass you
know maybe
maybe something legal a little less
illegal than that little taco vodka but
whatever y'all need
whatever y'all say i'll take it brother
thank you yeah i think if you had about
eight ounces of preparation dude you'll
do fine on a driving test man
it's pretty [ __ ] easy it's pretty
there's a there's over
there's over i think 80 million drivers
in in america
yeah yeah i think a little cradle might
help him right chin
i was going to say kratom too really
kratom maybe a little meth it takes a
little bit of anxiety off what's kratom
explain it chin it's uh
you ever seen that movie uh what's that
movie
bradley cooper no no no what limitless
limitless
oh for me it's like limitless i see
every scenario i see 50 scenarios that's
what it does
carl what makes you focus yeah it helps
me focus well it's a powdered leaf it's
just
all natural and it's related to the the
coffee tree right yeah i'd do one shot
maybe to calm down but bubba
i think the thing that's really going to
help you quit in the vodka
don't drink yeah they'll smell it
they'll smell for sure
they can't smell like not if you're like
it's mouthwash or you put in some uh
some
some cinnamon mint [ __ ] some [ __ ]
everybody in there looks like the mayor
of chicago dude they can't smell [ __ ]
i've been in their little beetle juice
nobody everybody [ __ ] is gonna be
fine dude yeah no one gives a [ __ ] just
trying to get through the day
yeah but look i'll say here's what's if
you can't pass that price jump behind
the [ __ ] wheel bro
and this is an obvious thing we have to
say this as human beings here and
brennan has two children and he should
have said it
and you are probably gonna have a couple
kids climb out of that [ __ ]
urban crevasse dude
crawl that closet yeah before you pour
half a can of similac into that thing
you're gonna have a little family climb
out of there in a month
but i'll say this bubba you can't drink
and drive you're we can't condone that
no
i don't know so sorry it took so long
for everybody to get to that
problem we finally got to it though if
he has to do it
we should be this nervous for that
[ __ ] driving test yeah and the cure
to nerves is preparation man the cure to
nerves is preparation
preach don't drink and drive yeah don't
drink and drive
uh and also it's pretty easy test man
there's cheat sheets out there oh yeah
you can take the test online though it
will give you the actual test there's
three different ones so
you can't memorize it really there's
three different tests we can find all
three tests online
and just memorize that [ __ ] and go in
there and pass it but again if you can't
pass it bubba
i don't want you on the [ __ ] road
because that test is so [ __ ] easy
dude i think he's more worried about the
driving aspect of the test actually
having someone in with them
oh there's also a big dog just [ __ ]
[ __ ] your license uber around then
dude i fell asleep when we had driver's
ed i remember falling asleep at the
wheel and they made me get out of the
vehicle
damn interesting well this guy
he's as a waiter he's becoming a regular
he's got oh he's got some pretty good
submissions
i'm joking beautiful young man and nice
to see him again
mustache like mine is the name allen
kyrik
kyrit close what up brandon what up theo
it's kayak from rhode island again and
this time i gotta catch shark tank for
you guys
today we're talking cats karaoke you
guys each take turns
singing popular songs in front of each
other i know theo's got some experience
from tpw
stevie wiebe who i'm sure is there
obviously has experience from his album
banger uh brennan i'm a little worried
about you but let me know what you guys
think
gang gang buzz buzz well chris had that
young [ __ ] album or something what was
that thing called [ __ ] smith
jank smith chang smith sorry
easy mistake one letter yeah first of
all
that's not a yeah no i know the guy made
something called
chank smith okay no no if that's shane
now don't
don't get confused also chet hanks just
dropped a new album too
yeah and he should drop it even further
dude that thing no
white boy summer was awesome until you
get to the second verse of that song no
no i like the whole song and his new his
new one is a slapper
i wish him the best though now you hear
uh his dad cut him off because he smokes
weed and drinks
tom hanks [ __ ] force gump cut his son
off for smoking and drinking tom hanks
who couldn't even get out of
the airport for two months or off an
island for years
yeah the guy is obviously stoner dude
is he in greece no he well he got a
citizenship in greece but he lives here
he lives in beverly hills yeah i wore it
i wore the white boy summer shirt the
other day
i went to watch rebirth brass band and
warmer white boys let me hear his new
track dog
[Music]
i
[Music]
oh
[Music]
oh
you don't really like it you're trying
to get them on your podcast no i like
that's tom hanks son i haven't had
caffeine for 30 days today what are you
doing
he's just got the same thing we've been
watching too many [ __ ] jres gill
caffeine
which captain i've had this morning dude
i ordered some [ __ ] dried beer blood
off the internet
i'll be fine
[ __ ] it
[Applause]
[Music]
white boy summer got your favorite
instagram [ __ ] dm in her number
hit the strip club by mike thunder she
let me beat it i'm the white boy
i like all this lady
another from the islands yes she looks
like rihanna yeah
let's see what you're saying though
first verse was fire then it kind of
came
off it's still good though good yeah
oh you said sushi katana
that's what i was looking for oh you're
looking for the catchy clothes oh my bad
doctor drake
i was oh my bad dr dre no but dude this
one
not dr dre how many views on that
huh 700 million 700
now the shark tank guy's idea chin's
gonna play the chorus a few more than
the episode when i was on andrew
santino's podcast which is his
most viewed episode i would like to say
that you're my most viewed is it really
yeah thanks man yeah thanks dude a
couple on fire kids over mill now with
you and me
really yeah yeah that's how this started
so uh
we to avoid demonetization with this
karaoke
uh we're gonna have chin knows six songs
all the way through that are written
down there so we can play them on there
and then we're going to try to uh sync
the lyrics now my allergies are popping
so my voice might be a little off but
you get the gist
we got that just all right so we just
picked us up my episode will you bring
up the lyrics yeah yeah
uh whichever one is brought up i'll
bring it up let's go first
stevie stevie you're you're actual
musician yeah i'll go first
is it what you gotta pull you gotta pull
a song from here no problem
you have a piano in your house don't you
no he does
i remember that oh i got this what song
is it fast card tracy chad
oh it's a tell us we're supposed to
guess oh no uh no no
okay wait where are the lyrics bring up
the
rip lyrics yeah you know you know how
talented chin is man let me think about
the cadence i seen him
think about the brows all their cuts you
got the lyrics
you got the lyrics beautiful anthems out
of them
i used to make love to a brother listen
to tracy chapman really
i just look at listen to nicki minaj and
lick this girl's butt oh
let's do it wow what a jam
oh how about chin beautiful it was an
altima i was a nissan altima
where's the lyrics they're coming okay
oh here you go one
ticket to anywhere maybe we make a deal
[Music]
together
[Music]
uh
[Music]
is
hold up man give me a chance all right
he was reading off yeah
give me a chance i want to get to the
course please please you guys are making
we hit the course earlier
just a little bit bernie you're making
let me sing the chorus let me sing the
chorus
i'm nervous with my allergies now record
let me just go right now of course ready
yeah
[Music]
oh where's this sorry i got to reply to
some emails
he's tuning out no no he's not we're
back here
here we go okay here we go that was my
bad okay
you got a fast car i want to take it to
anywhere
maybe we can make a deal maybe together
we can go
somewhere any place
[Music]
you got a fast car i got a plan to get
us out of here
yeah they're working at the convenience
store where you go how does this save
just a little bit of money
don't have to drive too far i just
crossed the board into the city
you sound like somebody giving you just
go to the we'll get to the course stevie
no
it sounds like someone told me she was
happy yeah
this is
[Music]
cool thing you went through it seven
times of course it is right now now yes
you
got a fast car is it fast enough so we
could fly away
you gotta make a decision leave tonight
and live die this way now the course is
coming
here it is right here
[Music]
and the screen went blank so remember
okay you're done okay all right all
right
i'm done you sound like a burn victim
trying to give driving directions to
someone
take it right up here
be nice
just put me in the back of the car sorry
bro
i'm just saying you sound like somebody
with severe burns
i'm sorry like who's in a full body cast
take a look at the swamp take a right
take it easy because you're a burn
victim
because you're a third-degree burn
because of the burns you can't move
he's like you're out of gas right you
want me to pick down nick
oh yeah let's let's try i'm gonna get
some gas
i can't help it dude this traditional
burn victim pose
my bad man i'm sorry oh thankfully
actually that was all a ruse just to let
the dog escape oh here we go metallica
oh there you go there you go
enter salmon that's how i felt when i
joined this podcast dude
let's go baby chin get your [ __ ]
energy up i'm trying i'm
trying this is 50 years old
on kratom dude he's got energy okay
so should i leave it should i leave it
up a little bit for you there you go
good job steve let's give a stevie a
round of applause oh don't get that now
after you did the burn victim
don't do that don't stop dying do you
get over there
yeah you're gonna be the song makes you
want to break stuff let's go
this is good man here we go i love this
this is fun yeah hell yeah
this is fun man i'm glad i came here
today
i'm nervous oh you'll be fine dude
hold on i'll catch it
[Music]
get in there
[Music]
how far do i have to go huh just did the
course just
you beat croco you got it bro
is it loading it's a legendary lead up
that's part of the song
yeah part of it's the lead is jim
playing the legendary lead up
okay
i wish i had a wig on right now
say your favorite little one don't
forget my son
to include everyone there you go
i tuck you in one way then keep you free
from sick
exit this
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
sleep with one eye open
gripping your pelvis shut it down
[Music]
oh
thanks dude oh man stephen man i will
say this it's always more fun when
you're here
okay and i mean
yeah killed it okay now if you don't
like you can pick another one
i got extreme more than words oh that's
metallica
is that metallica oh perfect
hey you can't look at the other ones we
might have to do round two
what are you doing brendan cheated no no
he picked them he picked the one he
picked brandon
there yeah this is a perfect one for
theo is it oh yeah
i don't know it's an old school but
that's
[Music]
shout out to my boy nino bettencourt too
man who was in this band
though oh this is a good song there's
lyrics yeah
all right so don't even oh you know you
got
because it's in a different tune okay
chin yeah just do it in like a c flat
okay
oh i can't wait for this this song is
gay
dude i'm sorry huh what it's not it's a
good song
dude the women love this song say yag
dude said it again yeah you're right
the will you start over
sorry it's okay so it doesn't help at
all to start with the sound
no so literally if they could just see
the lyrics i think theo would know when
to come in
yeah right yeah
when you come in i'll press play because
we're right at the beginning
saying i love you is from
you it's not that
i want you not to say
but if you only knew
how easy it would be
[Music]
to show me how you feel
more than words
[Music]
then you wouldn't have to say
that you love
[Music]
if my heart was dawning
through more than words
to enjoy you
feel your love is
real for me
[Music]
what will you say if i took
those words away then you
couldn't make this
i love you
[Music]
more
[Music]
what the voicemail experience papi
thank you very much dude i didn't know
theo turns into a
young chinese band when he sings dude
yeah
my i vocals my
vocals get so vietnamese when i get some
of those notes
and i know that i definitely i feel like
i'm in the uh
fashion district we'll do it again in a
couple weeks send in
songs chin should learn that was good oh
yeah oh i love that
that's good i love that
sweet okay well
let's close it out uh with just a couple
cats confessions
oh yeah you got any confessions what
about you spunk colonel you got any
confessions supposed to go back
in the back what's up doc yeah what you
got for us huh something you never told
anybody winker bean what you got
something i never told anybody i don't
know long island iced tea what's up dog
i don't know i'm a pretty open person i
tell uh when's the first time you ever
drank tell us about that real quick and
do not make it long
when i was junior and junior in high
school what happened where were you
uh my house jeff sex uh not that night
we ended up getting into a brawl
it's called a domestic dispute okay when
it's involved with a woman we say
domestic dispute
okay even if it went three rounds five
rounds you ever been to jail
uh yeah for one uh drinking yeah yeah
yeah drinking problem son ah i do it
rarely and when i do it i uh yeah i do
you need to drink some of that mountain
maro brother some of that hgh
i've been trying i actually got a lot of
dms
from people who watch this show that
have been like hitting me up like yo if
you need steroids i got you so i've been
looking into that there we go that's
that's fans giving back bradley martin
does he know anybody
i'm sure he has to work out though i
work out every day
he drinks a lot though he came over
monday to the studio hung over as [ __ ]
talking about out of bender yesterday
diddy
he's young you forget how young you have
a style bender dude take care of
yourself
start kicking some bags let's see what
we got man but
thank you i'm glad you're alive bubba um
and let's do something else stevie in
here looking young you got that haircut
on you look fresh man would you get a
philly fade
oh you got the kim jung young
you got that rapping no that's like kim
jong-un baby to have that mm-hmm
that's a good fade man oh it's so fun
but yeah this person has a confession it
fits for the the fights we just had in
the past weekend
hey guys uh got this little confession i
need to get off my little
my little chest uh
it's not too bad but i mean it's kind of
a dick move
but um i've got my own apartment not too
long ago
about a year or so and uh you know
all the homies come over if they want to
watch the fight you know a little boxing
i mean you know whatever whatever they
want to watch oh [ __ ] baby
you're a nice guy you know we all
usually you know throw in on the fight
you know that'd be like ten twenty
dollars ahead you know we watched we
watched the fight
didn't he what i need to get off my
chest
is i don't ever actually throw in on
these fights i
i just have everyone cash at me and then
you know i just use that little stream
you know that little
that little freebie you know so that
[ __ ]
tv they don't even know the difference
it's a good hustle that [ __ ] start
lagging
i don't know man the wi-fi acting up
okay real
yeah that's my confession is uh i have
all the homies come over and they throw
me about eighty dollars to watch the
fight
and uh eighty dollars a pound
total didn't even listen to the first
part
i thought i started he's 180. what do
you suggest to this guy chin what do you
think
what do you what do you share with this
that's a douchebag move especially those
are just homies too yeah that's a
douchebag pocketing
but are the homies bringing over all the
snacks and drinks and the girls
what i'm saying yeah and the money yeah
you're right but look oh is he providing
snack what i meant to say is he
providing snacks that's what you meant
yes yeah it's his new apartment he's pa
they're paying for foot traffic pay
double if you want a
legal stream yeah yeah yeah for ten
dollars to
even walk in someone's house is a deal
these days
okay so i think yeah bob i say up charge
them
that's what i say stevie what do you say
to this kind of thing have you ever had
to do this sort of thing you legally
scream [ __ ]
nah i've never done that but i could see
where he's coming from
dana put some guy in prison because of
it yeah yeah
so he says there's no evidence though
dana will voice track this dude i think
it does not like illegal streamers yeah
no it's a huge hit on their business yep
all right we got uh let's do one more
stream east live
yeah uh i was probably making confession
back in the day whenever i was 19.
i was uh like stealing stuff real bad
and i stole a laptop from the church
going to hell bubba and yeah
they didn't like that too much but they
couldn't prove it with me
the lord knows they're real guilty about
it the poor knows
i i sold it for like a half ounce a week
good deal for the weed dealer yeah and
that was about it that's about about it
dude you're getting a dollar
well you got a fast pass to hell my man
stealing a laptop from a church from my
church
the devil's lettuce what are you doing
dog
he did say he used to do it so hopefully
he's reformed and
and look we appreciate you sharing it
first of all man i know it's tough to
get off your chest obviously there's
some remorse inside of you as a human
and it's tough man
it's tough not to steal from the church
they leave all the [ __ ] out
and they also pass that whole like kind
of bucket of money around you know what
i'm saying
and they're not paying taxes either so
they can write that thing off i'd like
to know what kind of church too
yeah right because then i'll judge you
if they have a snake cage in the front
then
maybe give it back bro have you ever
seen that religious guy who thought he
could talk to rattlesnakes
get him in the [ __ ] neck did he die
oh i don't know if he did he died yeah
he definitely
not dude dad died the son is still back
at it yep still [ __ ] with them
rattles and shout out to my boy peace
that died there was a ki i talked about
him this past week and he died last
uh the other day how did he pass he's in
a motorcycle accident oh man
motorcycles so dangerous man it was
crazy dude he was saying
i was staying at the sober living with
him for a week he's in there no not a
good buddy but
just a new friend i just met him yeah a
couple nights we're all watching the
games and stuff
chilling chat drinking smoking the
second day he gets a motorcycle
the third day getting in the accident
been in a coma since then he just passed
away that's true rest in peace
yeah peace and peace was his name too
yeah rest in peace peace so you're kind
of destined for that if you have rest
you're gonna i mean everybody's gonna
die but when you're peace
oh yeah they just have to say rest into
them yeah motorcycles are too dangerous
look fun as [ __ ] i get draw so i'm stuck
on the 405 and i see a motorcycle pass
down the lane i'm like god that looks
fun
not worth it though man yeah it's risque
man especially if you have some kids or
if you have a
dark buttocks full of semen yep you're
already playing them dark arts
you should name it ooh does it have a
name
give it a first and middle name should
we maybe go out with a little palette
cleanser chin this is one of our choices
time in your life by green day oh yeah
and look guys thanks for thanks for
sharing whatever the you know the crimes
you committed or the
things you were carrying hopefully you
feel better man let that luggage go
dude just do something pay it forward do
something nice stop by a church and do
something good oh how about this leaving
a men's buy them another
new laptop to replace just donate money
to the church though living in men's
dude living amen before we sign up yeah
now right you can make a demands yeah
we're the best in the world back on tour
i'm on tour man i wouldn't say best in
the world but i would say you're up
there bubba
well that's nice you man you're on your
way man i appreciate you the nice words
uh
just want to let you know i got some uh
i'm i'm
taping my netflix special in nashville
out in the central east this year
but also i've got some dates i believe
it's the 8th 9th and 10th
in huntsville alabama those tickets are
on sale right now i'll be practicing the
material for the special
in case you didn't get to see dark arts
tour you can see it there
you know covet the latest but you know
it can't stop us anymore
so we're moving forward tons of tour
dates at theovonn.com
tour charleston albany
uh buffalo dear god different places
you'll love it all over make sure to get
any tickets through theavon.com
tour anywhere else is a scam gang thank
you
portland of boise is pretty close is it
savannah six and a half hour drive
i'm in portland maine oh that's far but
i bet you would go
but i'm going to maine man a lot of
people are like nobody ever comes to
maine dude
maine lobster i decided i'm going to
maine and i'm also going to burlington
vermont
uh as you guys are watching this friday
this friday and saturday i'm the haha
shop and friends
eric griff and i have some other monster
comics coming out this friday and
saturday yup this friday saturday two
shows friday two shows saturday at the
ha
those are almost sold out so get tickets
now and then end of the month i will be
in tacoma
washington at the tacoma comedy club get
your tickets at thickboy.com
aroma baby chin
hit it
[Music]
this is that everybody
stuck in the rut time to grab you by the
wrist direct you where you go
start it over please
and spare if you come in on the choruses
so make the best of this test
[Music]
i hope you had the time of your life
[Music]
hang it on the shelf in good health and
good time
tattoos of memories
[Applause]
[Music]
oh nice blue dude
[Music]
damn
[Music]
that's it baby gang stevie gang
you so much for being here man we love
you
brennan and theo fighter and weight i
got to go in and go hard in the paint
i do not think i am in flow black rifle
coffee i'm ready to go
i need a sponsor i am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts flow is
contagious browser outrage is thicker
than girls that are instagram famous
damn
hungry like i'm fresh off keto seeing
red like andrew santino
every song i hit like the great bambino
brendan ate the queso and the
of ritos but everything's gonna be fine
hate on me i do not mind theo looking
like the type of dude that got a pack of
matches in his pockets at all times
they sliding into my dms a couple of you
tribal couldn't beat them
quit playing like nintendo ds you don't
want to smoke like joey diaz
meaning y'all edible just got my
eyebrows threaded and i'm feeling
incredible
brendan's son hit me up he said it's too
loud in the club can you pick me up
[Music]
on a string
[Music]